if you're a regular listener of conan
o'brien needs a friend and you're always
jonesing for more
we have started doing something that i'm
having a lot of fun with on thursdays
we drop conan o'brien needs a fan and
uh this was an idea just because i have
lovely fans and they're really funny and
when i encounter them on the street
in life anywhere around the world they
always
make me laugh and i thought wait a
minute why just talk to
celebrities let's have a way that i can
have
inane insane left-brained conversations
with my fans uh people that listen to
the show or even people that just barely
tolerate me aren't necessarily fans but
want to crack
at talking to conan that's right i'm
talking about myself
in the third person that's a sign that
i'm i'm getting to like caligula
levels of insanity so anyway we started
doing that and you don't have to do
anything if you
subscribe to this show if it's in your
what's the way to say it matt if it's in
your podcast feed
if it's on your lazy susan your podcast
carousel if it's on your podcast
carousel if it's in your
if if you have conor bryan needs a
friend these will automatically show up
uh on thursday you do nothing i just
show up there like a bad penny
over and over and over again if you have
one of those
home depot pneumatic tubes it will just
come out thursday morning out of one of
those
is that pretty good that was good yeah i
auditioned to be
uh doing the voice over gaia on those uh
police academy movies but
they trimmed me down from michael
winslow so here i am now
hmm here's a door opening open
here's the door closing what what
i wouldn't be a sound effects guy who
kind of says what he's doing
as he's doing it well i'll just unlatch
this door
unless
i'm just going to pick up this voice
well better if time to perform this
surgery
incision would it be great if i i want
to do a scripted
podcast where i say that i can do all
the sound effects
and it's a scripted you know drama you
know it's a drama and i'm not even in it
as a character
i just do all these sound effects but i
don't use any sound effects devices
it's like all right listen you i've had
enough i've got a gun see
draw let's try this sona and i will be
the surgeons
and we'll set up tools and you you do
the sounds
all right so matt you set the scene and
i'll provide all the sound effects in a
way that only
i can okay
[Music]
dr mcsession will you please turn on the
ekg machine
you say yes sona you have to set what
are you doing
uh no it's a radio show
it's a it's a podcast you don't just do
it let's try that again
good god sorry you just
you can't see this ladies and gentlemen
but she just
silently hit a switch it's like
she's doing you to make yourself she hit
a switch
silently i thought you were gonna
no i need you i used to say like yes
turning it on now that kind of thing
let's try it again matt oh my god
all right all right
[Music]
dr maccession please turn on the
respirator machine
i do that you don't do anything other
than say you have to
like a radio show you play the character
and go yes doctor i'm doing it now
and then i take care of the rest oh my
god all right
you're crying and crying you started
crying
you just said you did oh my god you made
the motion which you don't have to do
because it's radio and then you said
turn on which is what i'm supposed to do
i like that the sound effects guy is
also the sound effect guy is just an
[ __ ] yelling at the actors this is me
this is why this show will never get
more than six minutes into the action of
this
drama this podcast drama because i the
sound effects game just yelling at
people
we'll try it one last time and then we
can give up if it doesn't work maybe you
should start with uh
you know different things since we've
already explored the device okay
dr mccessie will you please bring out
the surgical sponge
yes doctor review sorry doctor mccesa
did you hear the sponge say reveal
i yes i thought you said reason oh ring
out i thought you said bring out
oh this is the worst i thought you said
bring out and i went reveal
let's try again these are you know what
i'm loving is these sad attempts
are better than anything we're going to
come up with this is the worst thing
we've ever done
and uh okay let's try it oh my god
here we go okay
[Music]
dr mcsession please
[Music]
i'm afraid the patient is flatlining oh
no dr gourley
[Music]
doctor hand with the defibrillators here
you go
dr gourley i was going to say hand
paddle
we were doing so okay we can edit this
part try it again
[Music]
dr mcsession please hand me the
defibrillators yes dr gourley
hand over charging electricity building
clear electricity charge
the patient is making noises
and here's me handing over my
resignation i'm getting out of here